[Music]
you're new to social media right I am
yeah I know I just started on Twitter
and Instagram oh the joys of social yeah
well you know what's funny is that you
started finding in your travels you like
in foreign countries you find pictures
yeah my husband pictures of Nick at
pictures from around the world where
they're using his face in different
strange ways like there's one from India
mm-hmm and I think we have the picture
you just found this yeah
nick is the international symbol of man
of man
[Applause]
the woman that isn't reserved trip more
traditional kind of Indian garb and then
nick offerman yeah it's just like if you
need to know where the men's room is in
most countries in the world they just
put up a picture of your husband when I
when I think of the word toilet I think
of Nick off appropriate he would be
associated with toilets let me ask you
this I don't want to go there there's a
picture that you what are they selling
where is this from
this picture here oh that is from
somewhere I'm not sure what country but
it's for a dentist and the funny thing
is have any of you ever seen Nick's
teeth no they wouldn't even have teeth I
mean I'm not even sure you're how long
have you guys ever seen his teeth how
long you been married to him 16 years
you've been married 16 years and you
don't know if Nick Offerman has teeth oh
well honestly in the first year I I had
to lift his lips up like you're like a
horse to see I was like darn there any
in there like I wasn't sure because here
there's just this big mustache hanging
down and who knows what's underneath it
why they would pick him to advertise
dental work have you ever seen him eat
corn on the cob then he's got these guys
he's got teeth yeah I put it very odd
that they're using his picture all
around the world and he's not getting
many money but he must be very proud
that he is being represented in all
these countries oh he's just so proud
yeah
you